well I mean look let's be honest about
it there's no other words for it but
it's a car crash it's a Motorway pile up
and what they've tried to do in the last
24 hours is remove remove a couple of
the juggernauts
um while paying no heat to the rest of
the damage that spread across the
motorway uh you know the truth is the
the damage is done she you know they've
done the right thing in uh reversing the
policy on 45p uh on the 45p tax cut they
have done the right thing in inviting
the obr to report earlier and and put
out the fiscal plan how they paid for it
earlier but the truth is that that
latter measure is exactly what the lack
of it is what led to the lack of Market
confidence so they have reversed very on
two major things and that's the right
thing to do but of course what it does
for his trust is government and for
quasi-quarting and her credibility is it
means that the tough woman who's not for
turning shows that the first sign of
trouble she's for turning so there were
no easy answers once they went in all
guns blazing uh 10 days ago and I think
that that's the problem is that they
they took the view that
um you know they'd won the the
leadership election uh let's go for it
with big change and look I'm all for
ideology and a plan and one of boris's
great problems was that he had neither
of those things she had clearly seems to
have that in Spades but ideologies need
to be carefully done especially when
you're facing the sort of Crisis that
we're facing so when it comes to
ideology
um it's fine to have one but it's how
you apply it to the political
circumstances and they have applied it
to the political circumstances by just
smashing it through and they've been
found wanting within 10 days and as a
result that's why the poll ratings are
so bad and that's why she faces this
this clear threat to the future of her
government
this Penny wasn't right when she says
policies are great but our comms are a
word that I that I can't use on
Breakfast early
I I forgive me I didn't see the comment
but look comms is very important you
know I I can tell you that somebody who
was press secretary
um you know to the mayor of London and
worked with him closely up until he
became a prime minister comms are all
important but also policy as well and I
think that they've they've got both
things wrong what worries me is that
where was the advice to say you know in
a cost of living crisis why are you
cutting the top rate of tax in any
circumstance that would be difficult to
achieve okay with any audience and it's
not just the messaging and my worry and
my concern is that when they say things
like you know it was a distraction well
it was the distraction of their own
making and what they haven't said is
that the policy per se was wrong and so
I think it it is a comms problem but
it's also a policy positioning problem
they've come too hard too fast and tried
to do too much and that has unraveled
and what it's meant is that any sense of
political Capital has been burned in the
first two weeks and she faces a huge
uphill battle clearly with the
Parliamentary conservative party to get
the rest of the stuff through and you
know and the fact is that if she's
forced to turn on anything else you know
this could be and I'm not saying it will
be it could be the shortest liberatory
government ever
she said that she's not ruling out uh
more u-turns specifically on this mini
budget or this fiscal event that they've
called out I was speaking to the Justice
secretary this morning and he said yeah
no more this 95 that is left of this
fiscal policy that's what we are going
to push through
um they need to get the comms right
again don't they who should we believe
well
it's difficult to know who to believe
and that's the problem is that you know
the Prime Minister I think you've been
showing one of the clips from from Nick
Ferrari's interview with her on LBC she
did a couple of pre-recorded interviews
yesterday in which she was asked when
these are broadcast is it likely that
anything else will it will have been
well have you turned and she said no no
absolutely and then sure enough last
night we had the obr forecast and the
long and the medium-term fiscal plan uh
in terms of how you pay for all these
tax cuts brought forward and that's the
problem she's got now is a credibility
problem you know Boris had an Integrity
problem and and rightly that that that
smashed him you know out of the park she
now risks uh exactly that from a
credibility problem it does anything she
now says uh firstly does it calm the
markets and secondly is it believable in
terms of Voters and and the and the
Parliamentary party when you return to
get this legislation through so if you
thought that this week was bruising and
clearly Her speech will be all important
wait till parliament's back that that's
going to be a hell of a ride for her uh
you know the man very well how do you
think Boris will be reacting to all of
this
um I mean mixed feelings I think I think
it really depends who's got boris's ear
at any one moment a bit like you know
how he governed um I think that there'll
be an element for him by which he was
like told you so so you shouldn't have
got rid of me I think that blithely
ignores everything that that came to
pass you know clearly
um Boris ended up having a problem with
the truth and that's what did for him in
the end and I don't see the Tories
returning to Boris but I think it's you
know
it's helpful for him in the sense that
he's able to say look you know you got
rid of me I was the election winner you
shouldn't have done I think the idea
that he will be back if Liz trust fails
uh is ludicrous and I think what this
goes to prove is that
um after 12 years of Tory government
people are making big mistakes at
crucial points and they can't afford
anymore